[Music]
hello I'm pablo carrier partner
engineer at google cloud and today we're going to
talk about google computing
google cloud offers us a wide
spectrum of computing options to
create our applications from
fully managed ones where
we only have to worry about
writing our code to bring it  to the
cloud and we take care of the
rest to those that give us total
control and customization over where
we want our services to run
google computing is the one that gives us more
control to define how we
want these resources to be let's take a
look
at computer  ying we offer
disk and network virtual machines are the
fundamental pillars of infrastructure as a
service
these virtual machines can be
customized at all levels
we can configure the right mix of
cpu ram and disk that we need
and adjust them independently this
cpu can range from one  core fraction
up to 160 cores and pod  We can have machines
that have up to almost 4 terabytes of ram,
we can also manage the
disk independently reaching up to 64
terabytes of disk and we can
customize our machines by
incorporating up to 8 graphics cards and
even tensor processing units to
run our
related workloads such as sim learning  and tensor
flow
our virtual machines start up in
record time between 20 and 30 seconds
approximately until we execute the
first line of code
and in them we can run
predefined images with the most common operating systems,
either linux or windows,
or we can create our own
to make sure we always follow
corporate standards
when it comes to disk we have two main
flavors of disk
persistent disks available on the network
that we can configure their size
up to 64 terabytes of storage
these can be magnetic disks or
solid state disks  depending on
the needs of our workloads, they
are independent of the
virtual machines, they allow us to
create global snapshots and when we mount them
in read mode, several
virtual machines can read on the same unit
and we can resize them to expand
their capacity if we need more space
or more  performance
on the other hand there are the local
ssd disks for those workloads that
need the lowest possible latency here
we can use up to eight disks
each with up to 375 gigabytes of
storage and these are adapted
to the life cycle of the virtual machine
remember that  in all cases the
information in google cloud is always
encrypted both at rest and in
motion and disks are not an
exception for this
in computer and we also offer more
things not only virtual machines we can
run docker containers with container
optimize or is it our own version
operating system ready to run
this type of workloads
also computen gym connects our
virtual machines to our large
software-defined network that has
global reach and gives this reach to all
our applications
we can define managed groups of
instances that are based on
templates or on our images and so on
being able to read auto scaling to the
applications that we run on computen
jing these groups can also be
rational or regional, expanding the
availability of our application by
making it run in two independent data centers
and its capabilities allow us to
launch progressive updates of
our code or make versions
that we call the Canary Islands to
test them in production and find out how they
will respond to real traffic. We also
incorporate traffic balancing capabilities
and many more things, but I
have to manage myself in this
computing environment. There are certain things that are not
beyond our control.  And we have to
we worry about having them
always under control
my application the images of the
operating system or disk that is using the
cpu ram and the storage that
my virtual machine will need will have
to be defined by the user
and the network policies including the
rules  firewall how to configure the
balance or secure connections
through vpn other environments
are also the responsibility of the
administrator
let's take a look at a demo
to configure our first
virtual machine in computen gym go to the
services menu and choose computer gym
create a new one  instance either
starting from a predefined template or
defining the characteristics that
each instance will need at the moment
if we want to use a template
we can select it from among the
templates that the administrator has shared
with us or we can go
to the market place and choose from a
very  range of
third-party solutions  tested and ready to
deploy just with a click in this case
we are going to create a template from scratch
for this we are going to define a
virtual machine name
and we also have to define in which
location we want to launch this machine
to customize the capacity that this is going to
have  machine we can choose the
number of cpu and the amount of ram that
we are going to use from a catalog of
already configured images
or we can define it in a totally
personalized way this is a
fantastic tool to be able to adjust the
resources that we use to our
workload for this example  we are going to
use a small virtual machine
the next step is to choose the
boot disk again we can choose to
use predefined images
offered by google
images that contain certain
traditional applications or
custom images of our organization
in the advanced options we find
the management capabilities  What are we going to
need when  we boot this machine
a very typical one is to offer a
boot script for those tasks that have to
run when the machine is starting
up tags are another
fantastic tool to be able to manage a
collection of machines through a few
commands in this case we are going to call  to
this machine test
security options allow us to
use
and protected virtual machines when
we want to make sure that no one can
install any malicious code components
that could compromise the
security of my application google offers
this functionality at no added cost
when we select the disk we have
to have  Be careful not only to select
its size based on the capacity
or performance that we need, but also to
remember that the life cycle of the
disk can be linked to that of the virtual machine.
For this, let us remember if we want to
erase the disk or not when this
virtual machine  be a commissioner and what kind of
encryption are we going  sa use when we are
working with the machine
the last step we have left is to connect
this machine to the network and for that
we will have to choose which network we are going to
connect it to in this case we will place it in
the default network and if we want to apply
some labels of  network that later
allow us to create access control policies
based on them as this
virtual machine is going to be used for
servers we will use the server tag
and we will add another tag later
that identifies it as a web
and production server
the security teams can use
these labels later to create
those advanced control firewall rules
a trick that I really like
to start these virtual machines
is not to click on this button directly
but to know what would be the
equivalent command that would run on the
command line like this  I can facilitate the
template of my organization and
make sure that I always follow the
same patterns to
when starting up our machines when you start
this virtual machine it will take between 20 and
30 seconds until it is available
to start working with
it groups of instances allow us to
define from a template
collections of workloads that
will scale automatically  to
create a group of instances from
one of the templates that I already have
and in this case I will use a template
that I had previously created
I can ask this group of instances
to scale automatically or I will take care
of that task but it is a
common practice the  delegate this to google cloud
in this case we will use cpu usage
and ask for a minimum number of three
instances and a maximum number of days
for this workload
when creating this group of instances google
computing will take care of creating
virtual machines behind  To
accommodate the workload to the
computing needs that we need
at all times, we have  seeing how easy it
is to start working with computing
in offers great performance and
security speed when creating
our virtual machines
speed when accessing the network and
speed when accessing storage
with great stability traffic always
encrypted  and our data is also
encrypted at rest, they are virtual machines
that can be customized, we can
choose the ram, the cpu and the combination of
graphics cards and other resources that
we can customize,
we can resize these disks while
hot, also expanding their capacity and
use any disk size  in
any virtual machine and
billing for this service is done
per second we can also benefit
from discounts for sustained use the
more you use a virtual machine the better
price I will get and for those
workloads that do not have state and that
can automatically scale in
which it can  dispense with a machine
we have the  concept of
primitive or expendable machines that
offer us up to an extra 80 percent
discount, these virtual machines
will also continue to function in the event
of hardware failure thanks to our
life my grace jones technology that
allows us to provide extra
availability to everything  Said we
deploy on google cloud in
short
google computing is a great option for
almost any type of service and in
fact it is one of the
fundamental pillars on which we
ourselves build many of our
services
start using concreten gym for free
from today through cloud  google.com
free so long
no more